que vous voilà autour de la table il ya
un truc voilà qui vous gène est ce qu'un
détail physique
voilà où qui vous plaît énormément ou
qui vous dégoûte quoi qu'il arrive il
pourra rien se passer
cabaye ménez ah bah ça ça me dégoûte sa
falaise rêve ou c'est quoi sinon à
bastia et les poils d'eau qui dépasse du
nez ah ouais c'est le monsieur mais
parfois il ya un mois ferme
prenez ainsi un jour j'avais un copain
on a fait toute la soirée sur lui il a
20 ans et maria et adil bien sûr que je
vais dit un arbre m'est 4 août 2010 mais
il avait un arbre ici sur un tas de 20
airbus il y aura fois c'est quoi toi -
c'est quelque chose qui peut ou me
repousser on m'a tiré selon les
personnes c'est selon les circonstances
c'est les femmes qui ne se rase pas les
mêmes
ouais alors ça peut être très
repoussants et dans certains autres
circonstances
alors je vais te dire de certaines
personnes c'est est ce que tu vas faire
tu vas démarre avec moctar et tu vas
voir ça
[Applaudissements]
ouais exciter les poils sous les
aisselles sapena les enchères sur c'est
quoi la circonstance où cet extrait je
pense c'est aussi du courage et des
périphrases c'est que voulez vous et tu
les aimes coloré au naturel non
naturelle avec moi journée quand j'ai
fait le drapeau français avoue ses
quotidiennes le côté j'espère oui oui
c'est vrai merci au case est très sympa
oui il faut l'être dans les yeux quand
ils sont astreints à strabisme
coquetterie dans l'oeuf
ouais bah moi eh ben moi je suis sorti
et qu une meuf qui louche et dalida et
des convergences dépanner c'était quoi
convergences ou divergences et dans
convergent pas que ce soit si ça passe à
la qualifiant de ici ça veut dire elle
est comme à sa boîte où le taux plafond
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
galamaz compas la pâte veilleuse mon
père non géantes etc une meuf est là
elle avait l ush et non mais en fait
elle louche et cantal ont enlevé ses
lunettes ou un genre la vie de ma mère
je savais pas que ma mère ne veut rien
histoire mon frère j'ai commencé avec la
maaf l'amf et un jour au doigt ont fait
un bal on lève ces décrets mon frère et
comment si c'est pas loin des 10
applications mais comme je suis gentil
j'ai fait le boulot
mais c'est à dire je reste avec elle ce
qu'ils chantent lourds génie elle
s'appelait stéphanie stéphanie a donné
l'année c'est vrai que j'étais amoureux
d'une des guerres gignat maintenant
stephen enfer giné hiver chez nous il ya
dû avoir une vierge et non qu'ils aient
pas fait avec vous je peux vous dire si
ça sonne sur les doigts d'une main merde
et donc voilà et donc on avoir fait ça
faisait un petit charme voilà c'est en
somme c'est vrai que c'était auprès des
taux non parce qu'en fait je m'attendais
pas à ça voyez bien elle voyait flou bas
juste j'étais là et elle m'embrasse et
ici ça passe et ça passait mais non
c'est la v2 hanouna pour le prix d'un
ces bonheurs
gentil gentil c'est mignon isabelle et
est toujours mignonne et oui ou non
oui bonsoir bien ce qui me les poils moi
je suis très zélé poêle ou eux la
hauteur du poils pubiens
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je suis bien j'adore le côté californien
c'est unique en californie mais ça veut
dire que tu es totalement épilé mais
pour les autres il parle pas de lui mais
lui c'est une patinoire
amélie la bafin il avait sur la bonne
liste unique d'abord mais bon tant lé
parking av les poils mon nom mais toi tu
parles d'une époque ça avant 85 patois
ces prêts dans les poids des boîtes
tendance vraiment pour les films et les
sites
enfin c'est exister pas licite à
l'époque à tout ce qui était un peu
érotique les poils et étant dans 185 à
patra de 86 on a supprimé à quel point
c'est alors oui mais comment tu faisais
je suivrai que c'est sous cet habitant
[Applaudissements]
c'était bien comment tu veux quoi faire
publiatis en arrivant 86,85 d'accord de
quoi faire toi y'a quoi il y en avait
100 paris-sud quoi fallait mais on
déguise avec le côté un salon
d'esthétique 1 voix elle est allée été
tissés ndrl en à vue dépôts de jeu les
faire un mois la fin c'est sympa
traumatisée a pas 3d lui a demandé de
faire le sifel et reparlé samedi soir ma
vie c'est vrai vous la raconter son foie
mais oui bah oui elle est sa patronne
est venue elle lui a dit est ce que tu
peux faire le massif
elle s'est mise à quatre pattes elle lui
a fait le cif et après elle a dit à
céchi rentrer chez moi et mon père il
m'a dit qu'il retombe pas voilà
exactement n'y aura jamais de suivre
chez les b nouvel iphone vous c'est quoi
vous masser les cicatrices truc le plus
sexy voilà des normes
[Rires]
merlet
c'est tombé sur une hache quand j'avais
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
sur une météo fectivement mes bras il
manque de la peau car et moir oui j'ai
carrément un steak de décoller voilà
sans rigoler c'est vrai je faisais des
conneries et j'étais enfant je sais pas
j'avais 10 et frère tu tout est dans la
petite maison dans la prairie non je
suis tombé sur une il y avait une hache
rouyer qui traînait au sol comme ça et
aoued et colas taïg khris appelé ce jour
de cicatrices bassalah mois
[Applaudissements]
sérieusement
nous vous c'est vous qu'est ce qu'il
vous plaît ou qu'est-ce qui vous dégoûte
berne a manqué là moi ce qui me dévoue
ce sont les les grosses touffes très
poilu
mais où mais où sa jambe à l'intérieur
et vous quel état je suis très vite
perdus et polenta lui l'a fait pas bien
terminée terre dubawi kanyana bois vous
avez été koh-lanta seuil des 7
[Applaudissements]
ouais c'est impressionnant merci sa
boussole oui oui
alors moi ce que l as qui m'excite c'est
l'aîné un peu de busquets mais c'est à
dire les origines avec une voilà les
cause les mains pourtant j'aime bien
comme cyril banon vous voulez vous avez
un et marc mollet droit
je me suis cassé plusieurs fois donné
son nom c'est pas irréprochable mois
ferme et trois polonais et les deux
autres c'était comment donc d'élire m
entends rien je me suis cassé deux fois
le regard hagard bagarre trois fois ses
crocs fontoy un coiffant tous a pour toi
mais cabossé par des bagarres sexy pas
c'était pas des bas je me suis cognée
contre hull et donc je déteste les poils
aussi un en revanche où partout déteste
les poils le partons dans les oreilles
décollées bas et vous savez qu'en
revanche les sexologues sans terrifiée
parce que comme les jeunes ils voient
beaucoup de films porno il croit que les
poils c'est pas normal et les sexologues
voit beaucoup arriver des jeunes qui
disent ne faut pas dix ans avant de
refaire la musau d'antoine bons doigts
pour que le professeur israël nisand
était terrifiée parce qu'ils constatent
les jeunes qu'ils y font leur faire la
bulle et qui manquait aux yeux mais
voilà dire si justement tribunal manga
louis sénégal
et jonché des sucettes s'il ya quelque
chose de rédhibitoire ce sont les ongles
des pieds long way pas manipuler sa
série chez les cadets comme qui font
légion de pierrot bay à la piscine par
exemple
alors elle a dit oui oui ben y en a
partout vous savez un mais oui mais les
manucures c'est pas simplement destinée
aux femmes la pédiatrie dit qu elle
avait dû cure pour les mains un pseudo
d'accord c'était pas le haut oui mais
bon c'était mon neveu qui n'aimait pas
les doigts c'est aussi ce qu'a fait oui
mais bon je suis pas tout le temps en
contact avec des droites ni on voit très
rarement vous m'aviez dit que j'avais
des très beaux pieds c'est vrai je
t'aime d'une belle connerie a pu être à
fond sinon j'avais des jambes et des
pieds
alors franchement ouais franchement un
photo louis frémaux avait embrassé des
pieds et tanger tétouan enfants déjà oui
bah oui voilà à l'état d'épave merci les
pieds de choeur basque la tête mais qui
s'inquiètent des pieds ces personnes
personnes à risque avec ses pieds
arrêtés oui j'adore les pattes d'oie
away arides les rites de lyon du web a
raison chez les hommes et vous n'aimez
pas quoi j'aime pas les ongles des mains
l'on a way obligeront guitare et surtout
le petit doit la quitter
on s'arrête sur la tête de ma mère
des chronos denz et guitare l'après-midi
faut que je l'appelle se rappelle le
jeune et ses guitares à dominique renaud
denne au soir soit non moi bonsoir comme
jean michel mas le strabisme le
strabisme et si la voix est si la fille
elle a une voix un peu un plus graves
par exemple mais genre avec eux dès
lundi ou loups qui louche avec une voix
d'homme
[Applaudissements]
c'est le pas là-bas et qu'est ce qui
vous plaît pas du tout bah c'est pas
règles un peu comme tout le monde les
ongles les ongles sales c'est ça veut
dire ailleurs c'est pire j'avais une
même page où elle avait les ongles noirs
non mais ça met du maquillage elle avait
genre comme si bas n'était pas du tout
je croyais qu'elle était mécanicien en
fait plus jamais l'avais dit c'était
crac et luc vraiment irrésistible
voisine
qu'est ce qui vous fait craquer à tous
les coups à tous les coups vous dit elle
à laquelle rien artus et moi je suis pas
là dedans moi c'est ce qu'il ya dans la
tête
cet oncle charlie plausible c'est une
vache dans le cerveau ce qui me plaît
c'est toi là c'est quelqu'un de deux
caustique tu vois fausses et des fausses
a dit la répartie tout ça est
rédhibitoire qu'est ce qui est
rédhibitoire à part les pieds pied non
si quelqu'un n'a pas d'humour voilà des
cadres ici
et je vais vous dire les physique j'en
suis revenu brut mais pas les maigres
ouais c'est vrai à céret exactement ça
c'est vrai aussi mais me connaît mieux
que moi non ouais ouais ouais
à part vous vous êtes mince mais vous
remémorez vous dire